for decades gillane maxwell was the one
with the power but now finally the
tables have turned there's still a lot
of work to be done on this issue
but in this fight we need to celebrate
the victories and today this is a big
victory how do you feel speaking in
court uh it actually felt very powerful
to finally have a chance to speak and
and you know have my voice on the record
and say the things that i wanted to say
about how her crimes had impacted the
impact of myself and the people that
that i know and care about
victims of maxwell and epstein sobbed in
court as they spoke of nightmares panic
attacks alcoholism and suicide attempts
the lifelong impact of sexual abuse
after listening to those statements in a
surprise move gillay maxwell stood in
her prison clothes to speak
i'm sorry for the pain you have
experienced she said
i hope my conviction brings you some
closure i hope it brings peace and
finality may this day help you travel
from the darkness
into the light
gelane maxwell and jeffrey epstein were
friends of presidents and princes
they lived in luxury together partied
together and committed crimes together
maxwell grooming vulnerable young women
for the wealthy financial to sexually
abuse
today gillay maxwell did apologize but
not for her own actions for the
instrumental role she played in the sex
trafficking operation the judge alison
nathan told court that whilst ms maxwell
did acknowledge the pain and anguish of
victims there was a lack of remorse and
that is because she still intends to
appeal her conviction
there are
extremely strong issues
both legal and factual for the court of
appeals to take extremely seriously
to consider
and to overrule the conviction and
sentence you're optimistic i'm very
optimistic i'm sorry maxwell's priority
now will be to move out of this
notorious brooklyn jail where she claims
she has been subjected to unjustified
sleep deprivation excessive strip
searches and where she says inmates have
been offered money to murder her
how do you feel about a 20-year sentence
it's a very long time for somebody you
love
gillane maxwell will be almost 80 before
she feels freedom again as for
prosecutors it is unclear who is next in
their sights there were other
co-conspirators that helped this you
know scheme go on for many many years so
we'll wait to see uh if the government
takes action with respect and you'd like
to see that pursuit of course of course
this saga is far from over because the
pedophile and his sex trafficker
accomplice did not act alone joe pike
sky news new york